[Music]
we're playing white
let's go after him at e4 playing a
russian player ddt
and we're facing the karo khan okay so
there are so many good lines uh that
that we could play against the karo khan
and they range from and i've so i talked
about some of them yesterday
but um one oh the hillbilly attacked
yeah um that's that's the dekaio special
so um we could play the narrow con
that could be a possibility but i don't
really want to play that it's a little
bit too cheap let's play a fantasy
variation
the fantasy does not nearly does not get
nearly enough love
because of the reputation that it has it
has a very sort of shoddy reputation
undeservably because if you know how to
play it it's a
very very good line and it's incredibly
dangerous and also what's more
kyrokan players just don't like to face
it uh because of the types of positions
that arise
so h5 well i've never seen this move
that is just not a move
that is totally not about so what is the
idea of the fantasy well the idea is
obvious you're simply trying to maintain
your center
you're trying not to yield any control
of the center and you're trying to keep
the bishop at bay
see the problem with the advance is that
you allow the light squared bishop to
come out to f5
you're trying not to prematurely define
the pawn structure
okay this guy is probably alpha zero but
that's not gonna stop us from playing
the way that we wanna play
white's scheme of development here
is not uh particularly hard to
understand i mean we just played knight
c3
we developed the bishop generally to e3
and we can castle either short or long
depending on whites
uh depending on black's setup but if he
continues in this way we'll probably
going to go long
so that we can properly exploit this
these shenanigans knight f6 is just bad
oh what's up speak of the devil speak oh
man
fighting words fighting wars um don't
speak to the supreme leader like that
okay so knight f6 is bad and when
you play a line like the fantasy i've
talked about this before you have to be
flexible
right a lot of players like they'll play
the fantasy and they'll basically say
all right i'm a fantasy player i never
play e5 i never play e5
and that's a pretty uh limited and
narrow-minded way to be
because then when you do need to play e5
because you're sort of emotionally
associated with that line you're not
going to be able to
play the moves you need to play because
the situation is completely different
here the knight on f6
is uh very vulnerable so now the movie 5
is
clearly this isn't like playing the
advance black
is almost busted here particularly if he
goes knight d7
knight h so ugh this is
not the way to play the car gun okay
so had he played knight d7 we would have
played e6 with a typical gambit
now what should we do here f4 is
possible but we don't need to play that
movie yet i think we have a far more
precise
oh my god oh my god he wants me to lose
on time
oh my lens hillbilly respect
that oh hillbilly respect
oh my god a hundred gifted again
by dakai what the hell oh my god
you are spoiling me my friend
crazy stuff 100 gifted oh my god
what is that he is the absolute
boss he wants me to lose on time i shall
not lose on time
what should we do here i still want
people to tell me the best move it's not
f4 thank you i really appreciate that
you are
an absolute hero thank you for the 100
gifted
yeah we should play bishop d3 we should
stop him from coming out to f5 now he
has really
nowhere good to put his bishop and then
if we want we can play a 4 knight f3 etc
wow that's ridiculous thanks again nikai
100 gifted subs
i am always spoiled by the community
okay bishop d7 damn girl is right
all right so now the time has arrived um
now the time has arrived i think to
figure out where to put this knight
and as many of you guys had suggested f4
knight f3
is sort of the natural way of continuing
our development it
reinforces our center and we've just got
an amazing position here and look at how
passive he is also
the pawn on h5 is saying he goes bishop
g4
so there's no need to panic and drop the
bishop back to e2 what you need to
understand
is that not every pen is dangerous
that's an important thing to understand
particularly this pin
so we can simply play knight f3
and follow it up with h3 all right we
don't need to modify the way that we
play at all
he's making all these moves with the
same piece and he's going to pay the
price for it
oh god queen b6
okay so the key question is can we play
h3 is he preventing us from playing h3
clearly the the real question that i'm
asking
is um you know is do we need to defend
the d4 pawn preliminarily
now i'll teach you guys a really cool
trap so a lot of you are saying yes
because after h3 bishop f3 queen
queen f3 there's queen takes d4 and it
is painful to give up your central pawn
like that
but you should see the bigger picture
here look just try to understand
the extent of the development advantage
that you're going to have
in the event that he does that it's
going to be pretty vast there's no doubt
that you're going to have full
compensation for the pawn un
undoubtedly but uh there's a very cool
idea
that you have in such positions and i'm
gonna show you where i learned this idea
for the first time i'm gonna play a move
and then i want somebody to decode the
idea
i'm gonna play the movie a3 and some of
you are suggesting it i'm pretty
impressed it goes e6
now we're going to go h3 and we're going
to pretend to blunder this pawn
queen takes f3 oh my god i've learned of
the plan let's see if he
and the idea of course is to trap the
queen and he bites and here comes the
queen trap bishop b3
it works like a charm now there's a cool
uh application of this in the sicilian
which is where i originally kind of
learned this idea
knight g5 okay so he uh tries this but
he will not go gentle into that good
night
now a lot of players out of sort of
happiness you're just gonna grab the
knight and say well i've won a piece
this is good enough
don't settle for good enough try to find
the best possible idea do we have to
take the knight and let us queen out
is he actually doing anything with this
move the answer to that question is no
yeah queen back to e2 is the simplest
and his queen is still
very much trapped
okay this queen is still very much
knight she five kudos to black for
finding this move
that's a nice defensive resource and
this is a very nice way to cap off
the speed run for tonight on top of the
hundred gifted subs
okay yeah now he'll lose
well possibly he'll lose the knight this
is where you resign
well to quote mr scheible exactly
kind of we're gonna finish that honey
because my voice is really pointing out
all that screaming
all right
he started to think but a little bit too
late
he started to think but a little bit too
late now he does give up the queen
that's the bet and then i can come back
work okay 94 now what should
let's try to be precise here it doesn't
matter we're up a damn queen
jumpy with a five he ain't done
damn girl thank you jumpy for the five
what should we take with
should we take with the knight or the
bishop
now this is actually an instructive
point we should take with the bishop we
should take with the bishop because
the square on d6 is a huge weakness the
queen yeah exactly we should sack it
back
and the piece that is best equipped to
uh to exploit that weakness is the
knight
now you might look at this and say well
wait a minute doesn't he have a dark
squared bishop that super that defends
that square
that doesn't mean the square is into
weakness we could still slam a knight
onto d6 and that trade would be
desirable for us because we're up a
queen
now clearly here we should castle
and that's the bottom line you should
always compare contrast
this knight is much better equipped
really to exploit all these weaknesses
than a bishop would be a bishop on e4
would just sort of be biting on granite
all right so quickly understanding how
the position has changed
you can play knight g5 and go after this
pawn you can play knight d6 but the
simplest is to do
what don't there's one thing that's
hanging here queen takes a7 yeah why not
this wins on the spot
okay bishop e7
and there's many ways to just finish the
game straight away
there's one really cool idea we could
put a knight on d6
but guess what we could also put a rook
on d6
using the knight uh and i really hope he
plays something like f5 and allows us to
demonstrate
uh the finale even though we're up a
queen i have a really nice idea cooked
up
doesn't quite do it i'll show you guys
after the game
yeah one of the ideas was just a double
rooks or double rooks
and uh you know put insurmountable
pressure on his knight
i'll show you guys after the game what
the idea was
knight b6
now in such positions when you're
looking for mate you're always looking
at the squares right so the queen is
looking at the b7 pawn
that's a potential mating square there's
a move here that just stems naturally
from that one observation which is of
course
knight to c5 also as soon as his knight
leaves d7
he's relinquished control of certain
squares and that's one way that you
accelerate your search for checkmate
it's over
he's probably gonna rug b8 and then he's
gonna lose
okay he's going to take instead and
checkmate on b7
all right very nice let's quickly
analyze and then call it a night
okay so
fantasy variation uh this line again
it doesn't get a lot of love but i think
more people
found out about it thank you callahan
for the prime more people found out
about it when mvl
crushed alexsenko and the candidates
with this line alex sanko
sort of mixed up his prep this was
played for the first time in 1890
and it was played as early as the 1800s
twice morozzi played it
uh spielman played it so a lot of these
early attacking players
played f3 which is pretty big deal
because people
you know in the early 1900s didn't
really violate rules like that so it's
pretty impressive
um and okay like i won't delve into the
theoretical
um to a theoretical exploration here
i'll just say that
black's got a bunch of responses that
are very much viable you can play g6
uh he can play e6 very solid move even
the move e5 exists sort of a counter
game a queen b6
is a modern move that is considered to
be one of the best responses sort of
immediately trying to exploit the
weaknesses that are created by this move
so if you play the karo khan alt i i
think we'll probably face the fantasy at
some point and i'll walk you through
some of the lines
h5 is certainly not one of them and
knight f6 is certainly not the boss not
the best way to follow up
so had he played that fd7 we would have
definitely got e6
there's one very important concept which
is how should you follow this up
black wants to play e5 and liberate his
bishop so e6 often has a very important
follow-up to it that's just as important
as the move itself
this move looks a little bit awkward but
it's nonetheless quite important and
that is the move
f4 yeah you can also play bishop d3
first
because in this specific case you're
threading checkmate but after knight f6
it would be a very good idea to clamp
down on the e5 square of the move f4 in
addition
you basically have this idea of going
knight f395 white is basically winning
here i think black is
totally paralyzed black can barely move
this is crushing
so knight h7 bishop d3
and where did i get this trap so where
did i learn
this trap there there is a line in the
night or little known line
um and and one day i just like found out
about this and i was like man that's
kind of
cool it's kind of a cool idea um
and so we were able to apply that here
that's our pattern recognition and
that's just how learning works in
general you know you just
you learn one thing and then another
thing and you always got to keep your
eyes peeled for
chances to apply that knowledge
okay so
neither with f4
there's a line where after e6
white plays queen out to f3 and black
plays queen out to b6
and what move do you think white has
this is one of white's main theoretical
moves
vishy anand uh even played this move
well and you don't i forget it less than
a few days later a3
a3 is very much possible here
and if we click reference um i don't
know if you guys will be able to see but
yeah you can see uh
yeah anand against a nand against polo
yes
wow i didn't know it on play polygamy
that's kind of cool
yeah nan poligayevsky and
you can see this is a pretty popular
line and if queen takes d4 then bishop
e3 traps the queen so this is a direct
application of this idea
and it's a direct application of this
idea
and he uh takes the bait now you don't
want to make it too much of a habit
out of playing for traps but a3 also
happens to be a good move i mean you
want to defend the pawn anyway
so it's a productive move wow
police car this one likes 80 miles an
hour and um
this is a good movie okay so yeah a3
another cop just went 80 miles an hour
okay monkey s
yeah okay i think we're good
so the bottom line yeah exactly
ron and hi they're coming for me they're
coming for black's queen
so h3 takes takes bishop d4 and bishop
e3
indeed indeed and that traps the queen
in the game is over the one thing that i
wanted to show you guys afterward
just to fast forward to the end
is if he played the move f5
white has a very pretty checkmating
sequence
white is a very pretty checkmating
sequence
could somebody find it and then we'll
end on that note
it's rook takes c6 sacking the rook the
idea is to open up
uh the queen's control over c6 and now
another lobster pincer knight d6 you've
got to take the knight
e takes d6 and mate on c7 is unstoppable
totally unnecessary but still quite
pretty i was hoping he would
allow us to do that but he didn't oh
well still a nice game
okay um and that's i think a pretty good
spot
to end it's really late it's 5 14.
um that time kind of flew by
but um thank you everybody obviously
dikaio there's a hundred
gifted subs that's freaking crazy
and uh lots of support from everybody
else
always appreciated so thank you guys
hope you enjoyed um
hope you enjoyed all of the games and
all of the bullet today lots of bullets
today there will be more blitz tomorrow
i might play the title tuesday but we'll
see if not i'll be
uh streaming again in the evening as per
usual
and i'll see you guys later thank you so
much everybody
everybody for the support have a great
night and i'll see you guys later
take care